اليوم رحلتنا خاصه لشارع عاد الى الاضواء
لاسباب حزينه وهو الذي لم تختفي منه اضواء
الحياه او ضجيجها يوما انه شارع الاستقلال
القريب من ميدان تقسيم في اسطنبول الشارع
الذي كان عين الحدث خلال الايام الماضيه
وجهها تاريخيه وسياحيه وتسويقيه يجعله
الوجه الاولى لرواد العاصمه الاقتصاديه
لتركيا
مع التاريخ حيث يحتوي على عده مباني تعود
للعصر العثماني الامر الذي جعله مقصد
السياح فضلا عن كونه مكانا لتجمع الكثير
من السفرات والقنصليات كذلك في ميدان
تقسيم الشهير الذي يعد احد ابر الساحات
اسطنبول نظرا لتاريخه الممتد من ايام
السلطه محمود الاول
تقسيم الموسيقى الارتجاريه التركيه
لكلاسيكيه لكن البعض يقول ان نسمه جاء
لسبب اخر تتعرف اكثر على هذا السبب وهذه
المنطقه على ميسي
لمنطقه تقسيم مكانه خاصه في قلوب الاتراك
والسياح القادمين الى تركيا وهي معلم
تاريخي تختلف في الروايات حول تسميته حيث
يقال انها جاءت نسبه لتوزيع المياه
وتقسيمها للمناطق حيث كانت تمر عبرها الى
كل المدينه
ومن تقسيمه شارع الاستقلال الاثري على
طوله 3 كيلو مترات حتى منطقه كوين ومن
اشهر وهو من اشهر شوارع اسطنبول ويعود
لاكثر من 100 عام تتوزع في شارع الاستقلال
الازقه الضيق القديمه ويحتوي على اماكن
عده منها الاثري ومنها الديني مثل الكنيسه
المقبضه والجمع حسين ومتحف مدامتي
وللشارع قيمه سياسيه حيث يحتوي على العديد
من المراكز التكنلوماسيه وفنادق تستضيف
المؤتمرات الدوليه فضلا عن قيمته الفنيه
اذ يعجبه العازفون ممتعين الزوار بموسيقى
[موسيقى]
على
اسطنبول
في قلب المدينه
صباح الخير لجميع مشاهدي صباح العربيه نحن
هنا في شارع الاستقلال الذي عادت اليه
الحياه مجددا بعد تفجير دام استهدف هذا
الشارع وادى بحياه سته اشخاص من المواطنين
الاتراك الحياه عادت مجددا الان تبدا
المحل التجاريه في شارع الاستقلال بفتح
ابوابها مجددا امام الزوار سواء كان زوار
المحليين او السياح نشاهد الان ايضا
سيارات السيارات سميح لها مجددا بالدخول
لنقل البضاعه الى المحل التجاريه همم كما
نشاهد المطاعم اعاده الى همم العمل مجددا
طبعا بعض المطاعم عدت يوم امس همم وبعض
المطاعم او تقريبا معظم المطاعم ستفتح
ابوابها مجددا هذا اليوم كما نشاهد هذه
المطاعم عادت في مجددا الى همم
الى افتتاح ابوابها امام الزوار ايضا
نشاهد الاعلام هي وقد وضعت على طول شارع
الاستقلال مئات الاعلام التركيه وضعت هنا
على طول شارع الاستقلال كما نشاهد
تم ازاله جميع المقاعد التي كانت موجوده
في هذا الشارع والتي وضعت تحت احد هذه
المقاعد القنبله التي ادت الى الانفجار تم
ازاله هذه المقاعد ووضع الاعلام كمان
نشاهد وهنا ايضا على جانب اذا استطاع
زميلي المصور نشاهد عديده من المواطنين
الاتراك وحتى السياح يضعون الزهور في مكان
همم وجود او في مكان الذي جرى فيه التفجير
همم منذ يوم امس يتوافد المواطنين الى هذا
المكان لوضع الزهور والترحم على ارواح
الضحايا والتضامن مع ذوي الجرحى والمصابين
زيدان
شارع الاستقلال وتقسيم من يذهب الى
اسطنبول يعرف هذا التقاطع تقاطع مشهور جدا
هذا الشارع ما هو ما الذي يميزه يعني
وتاريخيا ماذا كان
بالضبط
في شارع الاستقلال ونكمل الجوله طبعا شارع
الاستقلال هو احد اقدم الشوارع
التاريخيه في مدينه اسطنبول طبعا في عموم
تركيا ااه مجمل او جل همم
محلات البسه او حتى اشهر المطاعم موجوده
في هذا الشارع ايضا هناك العديد من
المتاحف واماكن همم
للسياح لزوار المحليين وايضا المتاحف
تاريخيه هنا في هذا الشارع لذلك همم لابد
لاي زائر اسطنبول ان يزول هذا المتحف طبعا
الشارع ايضا يملك قيمه همم تاريخيه وقيمه
سياسيه همم في بدايات القرن الماضي كانت
هناك اجتماعات الاحزاب والجمعيات السياسيه
التي اسستت ل همم مرحله تركيا الحديثه او
مرحله الجمهوريه التركيه همم جميع همم هذا
جميع الناشطين والسياسيين كانوا يتوافدون
مقاهي شارع الاستقلال همم هذا الشارع كما
ذكرت له قيمه تاريخيه سواء من الناحيه
الثقافيه او الناحيه ال- اا السياسيه وله
همم مكانه خاصه لدى الاتراك ولده كل سكان
اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
هل هذه كانت المره الاولى واللي حصل حوادث
سابقه في هذا الشارع بالتحديد يعني في هذه
المنطقه تذكرنا بها
[موسيقى]
نعم بالضبط يعني تقريبا اييه اشرقت الشمس
تشرق الشمس في اسطنبول في الساعه الثامنه
الا ربع بالتوقيت المحلي المحل تفتح
ابوابه لكن عموما شرع الاستقلال لا ينام
او وهذا هذه مقوله معروفه دائما هناك حركه
وهناك ازدحام سواء الساعه الرابعه فجرا او
الخامسه فجرا دائما هناك حركه طبعا هذا
نظرا لهذا الازدحام الكثيف وانتشار
التجاري المهم دائما يكون هناك او في بعض
المرات كان هناك همم اعمال تخريبيه همم
كالذي شاهدناه يوم الاحد همم اذكر يوم في
عام 2016 في مارس ايضا كان هناك انفجار في
شارع الاستقلال من قبل الانتحاري فجر نفسه
في مجموعه سياحيه وادى الى وقوع ضحايا انا
كنت همم قريبا همم من هذه المنطقه حينها
قمت بالتغطيه لقناه العربيه هذا كان اخر
اخر اخر
كان هذا اخر تفجير في شارع الاستقلال قبل
التفجير الذي شاهدناه ايه يوم الاحد
الماضي
يروح هلا مطعم شو نوع الاكل اللي لازم
يجربه في شارع الاستقلال النوع الحلو
بالتحديد
الخيرات كثير في شارع الاستقلال اذا بدانا
في المطبخ التركي طبعا هناك مطعم المدينه
مطعم الشيف بوراك اذا انتقلنا الى
الحلويات همم ساحاول ان انقل لتكون قريبا
محل همم محل حافظ مصطفى همم هو احد اشهر
المحل الحلويات نحن على بعد المسافه من
محل لكن هناك ايضا مطاعم سوريه مطاعم همم
يمنيه مطاعم لبنانيه الخيارات كثيره صراحه
لا لا استطيع ان نصيحه في هذا الموضوع حتى
لا اكون متحيز الى طرف لكن همم اينما ذهب
شارع الاستقلال سيجد ما همم يشتهي وتطيب
له نفسه
شكرا لك من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان